hello there so giancarlo esposito the
actor who plays moff gideon and demanded
lauren has this to say about the
mandalorian season 3. i got to tell you
just to share something with you without
spoiling anything that season 3 of the
mandalorian is off the chain you'll be
amazed now this comment from esposito
just has me extremely excited and i feel
like there's actually a lot of truth to
this because there was a leaked man-line
season 3 trailer which i did a breakdown
of so you can see this link to the end
of this video but seeing the footage
from mandalore season 3 it just looks
incredible like the scale of this season
just looks massive it really feels like
they're going all out in this i'm also
really curious to see how long this
season will be will there be the same
number of episodes as the previous two
seasons or would the episodes run for a
similar amount of time will there be
longer because i got to say i'm a really
big fan of the longer length episodes
for tv shows so hopefully we get that
this season but whenever they do have
high hopes it will be the best season so
let me know what you guys think in the
comment section below are you excited
for this season and what do you think of
this quote from esposito and we haven't
already please like and subscribe thanks
for watching guys